super smash brothers is probably the
craziest gaming crossover in the world
it's the only arena where mario can
fight sonic
cloud pikachu pac-man and mega man at
the same time
and with every iteration it has put
together an even larger cast
of nintendo's most famous characters and
even some of the more obscure ones okay
hold on because i do know this one too
marcus marcus oh okay and who's that
marcus and tarkis yeah turquoise you
gotta watch out for smash hasn't shied
away from borrowing iconic characters
from other popular gaming series either
much to the delight of fans everywhere
but one notable omission from the
nintendo roster
has fans up in arms and ready to go to
war
one strange purple copycat who many
believe deserves a spot
next to some of the most important
figures in gaming history
who's that pokemon
oh what for the last two smash games
the hype cycle has been punctuated by
fans asking
the series creator masahiro sakurai to
make
waluigi a playable character
luigi he's still a nicest trophy
you might be asking why why would fans
want to play as a lanky purple weirdo
who seems to lack any social moors at
all
to understand the strange demand we have
to understand
where waluigi came from waluigi was
conceived during the development of
2000's mario tennis
for the nintendo 64. artist fumihide
aoki realized that if mario had luigi
for a doubles partner
wario would need one too and after some
consultations with mario creator
shieru miyamoto waluigi was born
now his name is probably the most
confusing part
wario makes sense to english speakers
because his w
initial is just mario's m turned upside
down
but waluigi's hat has an upside down
l which isn't an english letter at all
how the [__] do you pronounce an upside
down
l actually in russian that character
makes a hard g
sound so are you saying that waluigi's
yeah he's actually comrade waluigi
anyway the pun behind wario wasn't
supposed to be the upside down
m in japanese warui is the word for evil
so sounds enough like mario
that wario can be construed as evil
mario
similarly waruiji would be evil luigi
you just play my [__] mind but that
makes no sense in english
and implies that the prefix wah just
means
evil and for a time aoki was into that
idea
he even wanted to make wah peach and wah
daisy
before miyamoto shot the ideas down he's
not an official part of the mario
universe
and he's seemingly been relegated to
appearing exclusively in spin-offs
for the rest of eternity but those
sports and party games
are often made by third party developers
and
they have attempted to give waluigi an
identity
outside of being a crotch chopping
enthusiast
he enjoys defacing public property and
running from
the cops dancing like michael jackson
and he
[Music]
but it really looks like toad is about
to move on man
just move on basically waluigi
is kind of a piece of [__]
he's an enormous weirdo who doesn't
belong in the mario universe
and as it turns out doesn't actually
belong to the mario family either
according to mario luigi wario and
waluigi voice actor
charles martinez while mario and luigi
are brothers
and wario is their cousin waluigi
isn't part of the family he and wario
are just
two nice evil guys who found each other
did we just become best friends yup
which brings us to the question
why do people want waluigi in smash
well after the character was a
summonable assist trophy
in super smash bros brawl some people
got their hopes up that the noodly
purple bastard
would make his playable debut in smash
4. but instead
masahiro sakurai stomped on waluigi fans
hopes
by putting their idol on blast
reconfirming him as an assist trophy
and saying that even if you try hard it
doesn't mean you get to be playable
of course in the lead up to super smash
bros ultimate
which advertised itself as having every
single character
to ever appear in smash fans got excited
that their lanky violet sociopath
could finally get the recognition he
deserved instead
sakurai crushed those dreams by
revealing waluigi
once again as only an assist trophy
oh wow luigi no no
waluigi still misses trophy
this time they use them to show off how
assist trophies
can be smacked around and knocked out
just like actual playable characters now
it was insult added to injury not only
could you not
play as waluigi in a game with an over
70 character roster
the only way to interact with him was to
knock him out
fans were immediately up in arms
demanding justice
for waluigi with some even creating a
petition
to get him in the game with nearly 50
signatures and others utilizing a glitch
in the game
to spawn infinite waluigi assist
trophies
as if to mock sakurai's will but most
waluigi sympathizers took to twitter
to tweet directly at sakurai to convince
him to add waluigi as one of the game's
dlc characters
an effort that swamped his notification
tab
actually forcing out a rare response in
english
from the designer despite his attempts
sakurai
hasn't been able to silence fans nothing
can really stop them
the people want waluigi so we're left
with the question
why shouldn't waluigi be in smash sure
waluigi isn't nintendo's most popular
character
but he's relatable people want him in
smash because
they can see themselves in him he isn't
just you and me though
he's that random guy on your intramural
sports team
who no one knows personally but shows up
every week and gives it his all
even if he's trash he's the hero we
deserve
but according to nintendo he's just not
the hero we need
josh don't you think this is all a bit
of a stretch
would you say that i think people are
just trolling
really you're gonna
is the japanese word for evil
god damn that was cringe holy [__]
no it was just straight cringe it was
pure cringe
like if i crush up that what you just
said
and just made like a rail and inhaled it
dude
i'd be ha-ha all day